I just have nothing
come on I got this job this family
but nothing lasts forever heard you had
to leave in a hurry
it's never easy these days
so what are you going to do I've lived a
lot of lives but I'm done running from
my past
and know you're out there I know you
know I'm out here so we gonna talk like
grown-ups is that what we are
it's good to see it you says what brings
you home
we have unfinished business we have to
go back to where it all started
lucky us
one thing's for sure
it's gonna be a hell of a reunion
[Music]
I'm still family back together again you
got fat
[Music]
welcome back everyone its charlie happy
late-night video they posted this at
midnight so I'm making this super late
but all kinds of Easter eggs in this
this is a longer version of the footage
that they showed off at d23 so we'll
break it down we're doing a giveaway for
that giant infinity Saga box set with
all the Marvel movies all you have to do
to enter is be a subscriber and leave
your favorite moment from the trailer on
the video I know you have all kinds of
questions about what's going on with
Sheriff hopper dressed like the Russian
Captain America he's playing Red
Guardian he literally is the Russian
version of Captain America during the
Cold War through espionage the Russians
try to steal a version of the Super
Soldier serum and then adapted for their
own program he is the product of that
all kinds of questions about Thunderbolt
Ross and possible Thunderbolts set up in
future movies or future TV shows with
the new version of Black Widow Jelena
Bulova played by Florence Pugh so the
beginning of the trailer they start with
her voice over a cut with shots of
Budapest that's right we're going to
Budapest finally that's the freedom
Monument just to let you know that you
are in Budapest when this is happening
in the present day of the movie which is
taking place in the past what's this we
just did all this time travel during
Avengers endgame the voice-over dialogue
that she has at the beginning of this is
literally taken from her endgame
dialogue first I had nothing then I had
this family during that movie she was
referring to the Avengers as her family
but in this movie taking place during
the past you meet her old family that
she used to be with when she was still
part of the Black Widow program and this
trailer is crawling with a bunch of
black widows when she's staring into the
mirror here in this bathroom this is
probably right after she's gone on the
run right after a Captain America Civil
War like in the beginning of the trailer
and Thunderbolt Ross has that voice over
dialogue where he's talking to her
saying I heard you had to leave in a
hurry where are you going and she talks
about not running from her past anymore
I've done this many times before she's
thumbing through all the different IDs
all this present-day stuff with her and
Budapest in these scenes with her with
Jelena Bulova version of Black Widow
that's taking place right after Captain
America Civil War before Avengers
infinity war she's on the run for a
couple of different reasons one of them
being that she's a fugitive and they
actually want to arrest her on sight if
she's spotted by the Americans but the
Black Widow program in the Red Room also
probably wants to get rid of her too
because she's trying to bring that down
you kind of get a sense for the
narrative in the
she's trying to save her sisters her
family by getting rid of the red-room
she's tired of running from her past her
past literally running to chase her down
through the Red Room soldiers here this
is just part of that flashback and the
nightmare that she got from Scarlet
Witch during Avengers age of Ultron this
is her origin story when she was going
through the Red Room program you can
kind of chart how old she is just based
on the haircut that she has then as she
continues that voiceover dialog from
Avengers and game they flashed to the
first Avengers movie with the short
haircut her talking to Hawkeye they
referenced Budapest during that movie
obviously you see several shots of
Budapest and her running around in
Budapest during the trailer big theory
that Hawkeye is gonna show up during the
movie at some point and we see
taskmaster using a very large bow which
makes you think instantly of Hawkeye not
that Hawkeye is taskmaster then there's
a whole bunch of Winter Soldier footage
the soundtrack during this with the big
music drops where that screeching sound
sounds like it's right out of Winter
Soldier so the soundtrack will probably
be a little bit like winter soldiers
soundtrack the nothing lasts forever
lion is also just a reference to the
idea that she's still dead in
present-day Scarlett Johansson has been
very clear that her version of Natasha
Black Widow is dead after avengers
endgame this is all taking place during
the past even though there might be a
time jump in a post-credits scene in
present day with another version of
Black Widow like Jelena Belova most of
these trailer scenes only take place in
a couple different areas one is Budapest
the other is Siberia where the actual
Red Room program is where you see her
trying to blow everything up then the
separate location nearby where they're
at that cabin having that family moment
together fun fact - I know everybody's
wondering if Winter Soldier is gonna
have a cameo during this Winter Soldier
was actually controlled by Hydra people
and Hydra was not running the Red Room
so even though both of them were working
within the Soviet Union in Russia
technically they're on slightly
different teams all this footage here is
just connected to this other shot here
from later in the trailer they kind of
break it up where you see her in her old
uniform pre Avengers with the special
gauntlets it's more of a comic book II
Black Widow looking suit this just seems
like this version of Thunderbolt Ross
who actually seems like he's got that
crazy D aging technology that they did
for ant-man and the wasp to William Hurt
doesn't look that old and present-day so
I don't know why there D aging him this
much but maybe this was just meant to be
for she joined the Avengers so it's
early 2000s era once she finishes her
conversation with Thunderbolt Ross about
not running from her past anymore living
a lot of different lives she seeks out
Jelena Bulova also in Budapest in this
building walking up the staircase oh
this footage is from the d23 trailer
they showed off with her walking down
the hallway with her gun pointed then
having that funny gunslingers standoff
moment in because they both came up in
the Red Room programmes they know all
the same moves as each other
they're so evenly matched that they
eventually just have to give up and just
treat each other like actual sisters
although sisters do fight a lot that's
kind of the joke of this scene here is
that they treat each other like real
sisters if you're not a big black widow
comic book reader Jelena Bulova was
actually trained to take down Natasha
Black Widow and take the mantle from her
so when she debuted in the comics they
were originally enemies but eventually
became friends and started working
together with each other their story
within the MCU is obviously a little bit
different but they always changed the
comics a little bit for the movies their
fight scene is great they have the fight
coordinator from John wick working on
this movie so it's gonna feel a lot like
John wick fights but also they're using
the Winter Soldier soundtrack for some
of these sound cues I think they're
gonna go for a lot of Winter Soldier
type action in the movie just because
that movie did hand-to-hand combat so
well they also kind of used the camera
in this fight to pan around the room and
show you that Jelena Bulova also has
been on the run too you see all these
plans in these maps so it sounds like
she's having a lot of the same problems
as Natasha and that's why they're slowly
coming back together to be this family
to handle the problem as a family they
go on the run together then you get a
lot of scenes with taskmaster chasing
them down through the city so I think
even though it comes later in the
trailer when taskmaster is in this urban
assault vehicle and that has the giant
Hawkeye looking bow that he pulls out
that's him chasing after them on the
motorcycle this is the Black Widow
that's chasing after them that it looks
like she's either trying to save from
falling might be milena basta cops
Rachel vices character who's also a
former Black Widow from the Red Room but
it's kind of blurry so it could be one
of the other black widows from
present-day that it seems like they're
also training here with a slightly
different looking uniforms like the
program is still going on in present day
just like Winter Soldier would still be
operating out of Siberia in Hydra and
present day if they hadn't rescued him
she tells Jelena Bulova that we have to
go back to where
all started to where they were trained
as black widows this might be a
flashback they just want to apply the
way they cut this trailer that this is
where the black widows get a lot of
their orders from I feel like the
trailer makes it pretty clear if you
were confused before but there are many
black widows they're all called black
widows the reason why we call Natasha
black widow is just because she's the
primary version of the character in the
comics we see her in her white uniform
from the comics she gets a bunch of
black widow costume changes during this
she usually gets one in each movie but
within this movie she'll wear a lot of
different versions of the ones that she
had in the comics this also seems like
it's happening in present-day too just
because they're all sitting around this
table talking about the good old days
like look how fat you got Russian
Captain America talking about taskmaster
though I know people have lots of
questions people expecting some big
twist with his identity because he never
takes his helmet off it's kind of like
the Mandalorian never meant to take his
helmet off in the comics taskmaster is a
totally different person I'm hoping that
they keep him a different person so that
they can use him in different ways in
future movies like a future Thunderbolts
project but he has the ability to learn
people's moves on the fly and improvise
so he could fight pretty much anybody he
could fight against Captain America he
fights Russian Captain America during
the trailer they just bum-rush each
other so that's gonna be a badass fight
talking about david harbors character
make all the stranger things season
three jokes that you want because he
disappeared and it was a plot involving
russians but in this he's playing alexei
szostak off who like I said is the
Russian version of Captain America you
see him where his classic uniform to
this still fits so clearly it looks like
he's busting out of a Russian prison
here of some kind just because of the
way he looks it doesn't seem like he's
been kept in a deep freeze like Winter
Soldier is when he's not on our missions
but unless you know how strong he is
just seeing him bust through this giant
steel door even though he gets kind of
funny with it a little silly later in
the trailer when he's making all those
muscle moves you see all of his Russian
prison tats all over him if you're not
up on crime thrillers or anything like
that Russian tattoos in prisons are a
big deal they're meant to tell the story
of your life so if you're in prison and
you don't have tattoos is actually
really weird we don't see him use it in
the trailer but he also does have a
shield just like Captain America made to
look like the red Russian star they
start talking about family echoing the
things that she said in the future in
Avengers endgame they said that this
movie would be a lot of her
clearing the red off of her ledger for
good so that when it came to Avengers
endgame that's why she was so ready to
make that sacrifice so her death in
Avengers endgame will make more sense
after you see the Black Widow movie when
Red Guardian and taskmaster go at it
this shield here is taskmaster shield it
looks a little bit different there are a
whole lot of shields flying around in
this movie this is them literally trying
to bring down the Red Room
metaphorically and literally during this
movie yelling a Bulova firing off a
giant rocket launcher this giant scene
with her in this version of the Black
Widow uniform might be happening in the
past though it's kind of hard to chart
where some of these big action set
pieces are happening obviously this is
just a fraction of the footage there's a
lot of scenes of her fighting taskmaster
that they did not put in this that they
showed up at d23 so that might be in the
next trailer but it's basically the
scene of taskmaster driving her car off
of this bridge then they start fighting
each other and you get to see how his
abilities work as he mimics her black
widow fighting style I'm sure you have a
ton of questions about what's going on
in present day because the present day
Marvel phase 4 films will take place in
2023 like Spider Man far from home takes
place after avengers endgame this is
just the first movie that takes place
before all that happens so I know
there's a lot of questions about whether
or not there's gonna be scenes that
connected to present-day maybe through
the yelling of Bulova Black Widow
character but post all your theories in
the comments below I'll do more Marvel
videos this week so if you have any big
bonus videos based on this Black Widow
footage you want me to do just let me
know in the comments congratulations
Thomas pitch you're the first Infinity
Saga giveaway winner please email me on
the about page of my channel so I can
get your contact details I've got a
second one to give away so I'll leave
that giveaway open for a while too while
you wait for everything click here for
my breakdown of the Spider Man into the
spider burst - teaser trailer and click
here for my brand new Mandalorian
episode for video thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome I'll see
you guys tonight
[Music]
you